joining me now for reaction from
Washington DC is the Majority Whip of
the House
Congressman Steve Scalise a Republican
who represents of course the great state
of Louisiana congressman Scalise it's
great to see you now I was a pretty
harsh assessment by yours truly on the
big hulking Omnibus spending bill your
reaction to what I said well Laura first
it's great to be back with you and if
you look at a number of the things that
our president Trump's priorities they're
gonna be in this bill and you start with
our nation's defense the biggest piece
of this bill by far is going to be the
funding of our nation's defense which
actually restores the ability for our
country to provide for our men and women
in uniform and restore a lot of the
damage that Barack Obama did so we work
closely with President Trump and
secretary mattis to give him the tools
that they need look we saw two more
planes fall out of the sky last week we
finally are restoring air superiority in
this bill we're giving our troops a pay
raise in this bill there are tremendous
president Trump Republican priorities in
this bill but congressman I got to get
in here on on the sequester caps which I
know were considered a very harsh
measure and when those sequester caps
were in they didn't decrease spending
they decrease the rate of increase in
spending that's crazy Washington speak
so the military did have some cutbacks
but the cutbacks were across-the-board
and the budget deficit under Obama and
for a few years did begin to go down so
now Republicans are in charge and it's
like well the military needs another
three hundred billion and this project
needs a couple you know 20 billion here
and 30 billion there and all of a sudden
we turn around and the Republicans are
the party of big spending congressmen so
how do we as conservatives hold up that
mantle of fiscal responsibility if
indeed were blowing the budget again
because you know we're we're you know
we're gonna spend more money in the
military well and I think again one of
our basic functions as a government is
to fund and provide for a National
Defense we shouldn't pit fiscal
discipline against providing for our
nation's defense another billion dollars
operable so you can't know right but
look we have a billion dollars oh it's a
lot it's a but again we
you talk about restoring the cuts that
Barack Obama made this is not being done
on the backs of if you look at what's
what's driving our debt we all know
what's driving our national debt and
that is mandatory spending we've
addressed that in the house but also if
you look at some of the problems in
terms of what's what the CBO scores say
is creating the trillion-dollar deficits
they say our tax cut bill is what blue a
trillion dollar deficit hole in our
budget I don't agree with that Laura
because we're seeing economic growth
we're actually seeing not only companies
given bonuses and pay raise to workers
but we're seeing more people get out of
the unemployment rate anymore not going
to get more money in Washington because
of the tax cut that trillion dollar down
I'd have no doubt about that but but
this is an opportunity congressman to
defund sanctuary cities and to get the
real money for the wall that the
president campaigned on and he won the
election on that wall defund Planned
Parenthood you heard that soundbite half
a billion dollars I know you agree with
me on this but a half a billion dollars
to Planned Parenthood the Republicans
are in charge and they punt it I that is
mine whoa hold on a second and look I
share your frustration there but if you
look at this bill President Trump will
have the ability to defund sanctuary
cities in this bill and and I support
the president in saying we're not only
gonna go after sanctuary cities but
sanctuary states and there's a big fight
going along I'm glad that President
Trump said we're gonna finally confront
this he has that ability funding of the
wall that's something we're negotiating
in these final stages right now that
hasn't been completely released yet but
I think you have the ability for the
president to start building the wall in
this bill yeah number of other wins for
the president that we have in this bill
but ultimately if you want to talk about
what's driving our debt number one I
don't think tax cuts are gonna blow a
trillion dollar hole in the budget and
you're already seeing economic growth I
believe in free markets economic growth
is actually happening and we're gonna
ultimately have less than the trillion
dollar deficit but we have have to save
Medicare from bankruptcy we've got a
safe choice with the American people and
you know I adore you so I'm not trying
to get either but we have to be honest
with the American people
Planned Parenthood will be fully funded
in this bill correct not fully funded
but look
they've been getting funding for a long
time we're trying to roll that back our
health care bill which passed the House
and failed in the Senate by one vote
would have fully defunded Ryan
Parenthood so we got to continue that
fight I'm not done with that fight I've
worked very closely with all the
pro-life groups and none of us should
give up on that fight but we are going
to be rolling back some of the money
that they're getting and and we've got
to continue battling to get this done
the sanctuary cities is such a winner
politically for the country and the
president will pursue that that this you
know this this big Gateway project that
you were talking about a big dogle
hopefully we're gonna be able to defund
that in this bill so again you know take
a look when the final link is dried a
lot of these projects you're talking
about I agree with you completely on and
once this bill is done I think you're
going to still have that ability while
restoring our nation's defense to the
superiority it deserves in restoring a
lot of the cuts that Barack Obama made
to our mountain isn't a trump wants this
this bill let's go to let's go to
special counsel both you now you've
joined Kevin McCarthy other leaders in
the House and the Senate all believing
it's time for a second Special Counsel
to examine the russian russian probe and
the hillary email probe given what we've
learned about the FBI why a second
special counsel with endless budgets and
almost no accountability how is that the
right answer well Laura I think right
now we don't have the accountability
that we deserve and we've seen serious
questions questions raised from the
houses investigation into what's going
on with the Special Counsel and it's not
just the Special Counsel that goes far
beyond that and so you see the abuses
potentially of the FISA process which is
a really important process but if FBI
agents were abusing that and and I think
mostly this is coming from some of the
top-level FBI agents going back to the
Obama regime this isn't our local field
offices the FBI does great work at the
local level but frankly some of their
credibility has been called into
question about these reports that have
come out and I think a special a second
special counsel to look into some of
these abuses that we've seen in the
serious questions that are raised I
think is well in order to restore the
confidence in the FBI that's desperately
needed are you surprised
congressman Scalise that after we
learned that the FBI blew two chances to
intervene against Nicholas Cruz both on
that YouTube video posting and in the on
the tip line when he was basically told
he's gonna blow up a school that we
never as far as I can tell we never have
seen Christopher Ray the FBI director
address how this happened how we're
gonna prevent this from happening again
does that concern you in the wake of the
parkland shooting it absolutely does
Lauren I know you and I have talked
about this before one of the passions I
have is to find find out exactly who had
his file I mean Cruz said I'm gonna be a
professional school shooter he told
people he was going to do theirs right
and the FBI has they come out we need we
need to have true accountability and I
want to know the names of everybody in
the FBI a who handled that file and made
decisions to not pursue him and
ultimately that led to him going out in
massacre and 17 people it should have
never happened in the FBI dropped the
ball you saw some problems that local
law enforcement as well that anger me
too but in terms of oversight here we we
have oversight over the FBI and I think
we deserve and the public deserves to
know just why the FBI dropped the ball
on this critically important case
Congressman Steve Scalise always great
having you on thank you so much sir